Well, the other interesting things that we have the teams do,
and the JerseySquare guys was a great example,
is to the start to put together the unit economics,
the metrics that matter for both revenue and cost.
So, then we're going to take the annual subscription revenue, $199,
and see what their business looks like.
So they assumed that the cost of a jersey with 25% off to them,
that is, to JerseySquare was $150.
They think they'll be able to rent it five times during the year
but their shipping cost was about $9, their cleaning cost a dollar
processing cost a dollar
and their customer acquisition and activation cost $25 a team
and so if you take a look at their unit costs
you add all this up
it's $230 but their revenue was only $199.
Why would they do this? 'Cos they were going to lose $31 a year?
Well, remember this was to acquire a customer.
But what you need to look at is the customer lifetime value.
What happens when this customer renews for the next year?
Well, in the next year, you don't have that jersey cost
because you're still turning that jersey.
He might have only used it two or three or four times.
and you don't have the customer acquisition cost
because you already acquired that customer.
You still have your shipping, cleaning and processing costs
but your unit costs are now $55
and if you get 60% retention, your net for those customers who stay longer than a year is $86.
You can immediately see some of the fallacies
in these first back of the envelope calculations.
What if they use the jerseys seven times a year?
You're actually buying more jerseys per year
and actually you're losing money in year two, three and four
so you might want to be limiting the number of times
you can actually rent a jersey in a year
or you could just be changing your revenue model.
But this is a good visual way to start thinking about
how to start doing the math for metrics that matter.